Traduttore: Cecilia Bernabeni
Revisore: SILVIA ALLONE
“Quanti di voi si svegliano la mattina
convinti di fare la differenza?”
Questa è la domanda che ha fatto
una nostra studentessa
di 16 anni, Kathryn,
ai suoi compagni di classe.
E nessuno ha alzato la mano.
E questa è una domanda
che mi faccio anch'io, da diverso tempo.
Da sempre, in particolare,
sono appassionata di temi ambientali.
Mi ricordo da piccola,
sul mio primo National Geographic,
vedevo le foto
dell'Amazzonia che bruciava;
e poi, crescendo, mi sono accorta
che i problemi ambientali
non erano solo dall'altra parte del mondo,
ma erano anche intorno a noi.
Erano dei problemi globali,
ma anche locali.
Penso ai problemi della cementificazione,
che riguardavano proprio il paesaggio
che vivevo tutti i giorni.
I problemi, quindi, della perdita
di identità del nostro paesaggio,
e anche di noi stessi.
E poi penso ai problemi
del cambiamento climatico,
che sono a livello globale
e che hanno reso una singola specie,
la specie umana,
in grado di modificare
irrimediabilmente il clima,
dando vita a quella
che è l'epoca dell'antropocene.
Tutte queste problematiche
mi hanno sempre spinta
a cercare di fare qualcosa,
e ho provato a cercare la mia strada.
Quindi mi sono laureata all'università,
ho fatto vari tipi di esperienza,
dopodiché sono approdata
in un centro di ricerche
che si occupava proprio di questi temi:
del paesaggio, del consumo di suolo,
della valutazione di piani e programmi.
Era quello per cui avevo studiato.
Però sentivo - quando tornavo
a casa la sera -
non mi sentivo veramente soddisfatta,
sentivo che mancava
effettivamente qualcosa.
Non riuscivo a capire bene che cosa -
e poi cosa è successo?
Penserete: ho lasciato, ho mollato tutto,
ho cambiato completamente vita.
No, in realtà ero attaccata
a quel tipo di lavoro che avevo,
perché comunque c'erano i miei compagni
con cui avevo frequentato l'università.
Il lavoro era gradevole,
ero diciamo nella mia comfort zone,
quindi non avevo il coraggio di cambiare.
Poi è successo un elemento esterno,
un elemento che ha portato
alla chiusura del mio contratto
perché erano finiti i fondi
per quella ricerca
e questa cosa mi ha messo molto in crisi.
Non sapevo effettivamente che cosa fare.
Avevo due strade aperte, davanti a me,
che vedevo in quel momento:
o cercare di arrivare
in un'impresa tradizionale,
quindi utilizzare la mia laurea,
quello che avevo studiato,
o provare a partire da me,
e dalle mie passioni,
e provare a mettermi in gioco.
E ho scelto questa seconda strada.
E quindi ho fondato un'associazione
che si occupava proprio dei temi
del paesaggio e dell'ambiente
e cercava di coinvolgere
i Comuni e le Istituzioni.
Man mano che portavo avanti
questi progetti,
la cosa di cui mi sono accorta
è che stavo attingendo a dei talenti
che non avevo mai considerato.
In particolare avevo considerato
carriere come completamente separate
le mie passioni per l'arte
e la mia passione per l'ambiente.
E tramite quell'esperienza,
io stavo unendo tante cose
che mi piacevano, tanti interessi.
Ho scoperto anche dei talenti
che non pensavo di avere
rispetto proprio alla capacità
di connettere le persone,
di gestire progetti,
di utilizzare l'arte o il teatro
come uno strumento di comunicazione
di progetti ambientali.
E quindi tante cose
che non sapevo di avere sono emerse.
E tutto questo percorso
mi ha portato alla consapevolezza
di cercare di condividere
quello che avevo appreso di me poi,
e che poi ero riuscita
a fare concretamente
con i giovani, con le nuove generazioni.
E in particolare, lavorare su di loro
per dare degli strumenti di cambiamento
delle loro vite e poi del mondo,
del loro territorio e del loro contesto.
È nata così l'azienda che ho creato,
che si occupa proprio di questo
e che dal 2014 ha coinvolto
più di 8000 ragazzi, in tutta Italia,
su progetti per fare la differenza.
E questo per me era inimmaginabile,
quando pensavo a questa possibile strada.
Era completamente inimmaginabile.
E mi ricordo nel corridoio un collega,
proprio quando stavo chiudendo
la mia esperienza di lavoro precedente,
che mi aveva chiesto: “Cosa farai dopo?”
Gli ho detto: “Io so cosa voglio fare,
so che voglio occuparmi
di giovani e ambiente,
e in qualche modo lo farò”.
E ho scoperto una sicurezza, anche qui,
che non pensavo mi appartenesse.
Offrire ai giovani
degli strumenti di cambiamento
è stata un'esperienza
che ha permesso, in qualche modo,
di cambiare le cose,
partendo in primis dal talento.
La cosa infatti su cui vogliamo ragionare,
vogliamo portare nelle classi
è proprio far riflettere i giovani
su quali sono i loro talenti.
Quali sono le loro capacità
e le loro attitudini.
E sembra una cosa scontata;
ma spesso a scuola non si ragiona
su quali siano effettivamente
le proprie capacità.
Quindi una domanda che facciamo
ai ragazzi è, in particolare,
“Che cosa sei bravo a fare?
Che cosa ti piace fare?"
E anche "Che cosa gli altri,
le persone che ti vogliono bene,
ti riconoscono come qualcosa
in cui sei bravo effettivamente?”
E quando i ragazzi sono obbligati
a riflettere su questo,
vediamo che le cose cambiano.
A volte qualcuno dice:
“No, io non so fare assolutamente niente”.
Poi prova a riflettere,
e effettivamente trova
un talento, trova qualcosa.
E in particolare, una delle storie
che volevo portare oggi,
quindi come ricercare i propri talenti
possa effettivamente farci attingere
a delle energie
che non pensavamo di avere.
Vi racconto appunto la storia
di uno dei nostri studenti.
La storia di uno studente
che ha passato cinque ore
chiuso in un armadio.
Adesso vi spiegherò perché:
questo per me, e magari anche per voi,
è semplicemente un pastello.
Per questo ragazzo,
un pastello era uno strumento
per educare le giovani generazioni,
per poter insegnare ai bambini
a disegnare la natura
e poter insegnare loro
che non si butta via niente.
E che quando si pianta,
quello che rimane del pastello -
che è, in quel caso, il pastello
che aveva inventato Ottavian,
era un pastello con un seme;
quando si pianta,
da quello che rimane del pastello
si può generare una pianta
che dà origine a un frutto, un fiore
che è dello stesso colore del pastello.
Octavian è un nostro studente
che ha creato questo progetto,
una startup che realizza
questi pastelli integrati col seme
proprio per i bambini.
Era un ragazzo che veniva considerato,
e lui stesso si considerava,
una persona, uno studente
in qualche modo mediocre.
Non era - non aveva del commitment,
come lo definiva lui stesso.
E in questo progetto
si è appassionato talmente tanto,
e ha scoperto che quello che faceva
nel proprio tempo libero,
quindi quello che faceva
al di fuori della scuola,
dedicarsi ai video,
dedicarsi alla comunicazione,
poteva effettivamente essere
qualcosa su cui lavorare.
Si è messo allora in gioco
all'interno di questo progetto,
e ha passato cinque ore
chiuso in un armadio,
per cercare di registrare
il video della sua startup
che fosse il più perfetto possibile,
perché i vestiti all'interno dell'armadio
assorbivano il suono.
E questa esperienza gli ha permesso,
in qualche modo, di cambiare la sua vita,
perché ha scoperto di avere
questo talento nella comunicazione,
è riuscito a entrare
in un'università importante,
che si occupa di comunicazione,
ha vinto delle borse di studio.
E quindi, con una riflessione
sui propri talenti,
è riuscito in qualche modo
a trovare quella che è la sua strada.
Questo è un esempio, appunto,
di come, attingendo alle proprie risorse,
si possa fare la differenza,
in primis in se stessi.
La seconda cosa che vi volevo portare,
era proprio l'importanza di mettere
a contatto gli studenti e i giovani
con qualcosa che non conoscono,
qualcosa che li può
effettivamente ispirare.
Quello che abbiamo notato
è che portarli a contatto
con realtà innovative,
ma anche con luoghi
che sono diversi dal solito,
può effettivamente fare
la differenza nei ragazzi.
Questo che trovate sulla slide
è appunto un biglietto
che ci ha lasciato un nostro studente,
uno studente di una scuola
che era in un contesto
abbastanza difficile,
uno studente che i propri professori
definivano uno studente
abbastanza difficile.
E attraverso un'esperienza
in montagna di tre giorni,
con un focus sui temi ambientali,
effettivamente questo ragazzo
ha comunicato in maniera
completamente diversa
e alla fine se ne è andato
lasciandoci questo biglietto.
Si è sentito libero, si è riscoperto
e ha riscoperto anche un modo differente
di comunicare se stesso agli altri.
L'ultima cosa di cui volevo parlare,
quindi sicuramente un percorso
per fare la differenza,
riguarda la scoperta dei propri talenti,
il venire a contatto con qualcosa
che è fuori dal nostro quotidiano,
quindi uscire da quelli
che sono i nostri confini soliti
e venire a contatto con realtà
che magari pensiamo a priori
non ci possono interessare.
La terza cosa che però vogliamo
portare ai giovani, nelle scuole
è cercare di aiutarli a fare la differenza
anche in un contesto legato
al loro territorio.
E quindi quello che facciamo
è proprio cercare di aiutarli
a ragionare rispetto alla collettività.
All'inizio vi parlavo di Kathryn;
i suoi compagni di classe
non hanno alzato la mano
rispetto alla domanda che lei aveva fatto:
"Come si fa a avere un impatto?"
Però poi, tutti insieme,
Kathryn e i suoi compagni,
si sono messi e sono riusciti
a realizzare un progetto
che ha effettivamente trasformato
la città in cui risiedeva la loro scuola,
la città di Como.
Si sono messi insieme,
e hanno progettato un'idea semplice:
un applicativo che incentivava
le persone ad andare a piedi,
e quindi faceva in modo
di cercare di risolvere
quello che era un problema
della città di Como:
l'inquinamento ambientale,
l'inquinamento dell'aria,
e il fatto che il centro storico
stesse in qualche modo perdendo
il suo centro di interesse.
Quindi questi ragazzi
hanno realizzato questo applicativo,
hanno creato una rete di commercianti
che davano degli sconti
alle persone che andavano a piedi.
Hanno mobilitato i cittadini
e hanno sensibilizzato
centinaia di persone su queste tematiche,
organizzando delle camminate
intorno alla città
con famiglie, bambini più piccoli,
genitori e così via.
Ed è stato bello,
perché tutti insieme hanno capito
che potevano cercare
di approfondire il proprio talento,
ma potevano anche metterlo
in connessione con altri
e potevano cercare di realizzare progetti
che portavano un valore
alla propria città.
Quindi, questo è il messaggio
che vi voglio lasciare.
Tutti noi come cittadini, studenti,
genitori, formatori,
qualunque sia il nostro ruolo,
possiamo cercare
di ascoltare i nostri talenti,
di metterli in gioco
e di lavorare tutti per la costruzione
di un mondo migliore.
Grazie.
(Applausi)